[Music]
hey there and welcome back to GameSpot's
three-part series on The Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt in yesterday's video we explored
the history of the franchise and gave
you a look at the prologue area where
I'll get your first lessons in witching
today we travel further much further
into bustling cities across craggy
Island and down into farmlands consumed
by monstrous beasts so put on your best
pair of shoes today we explored the
world of wild hunt
okay let's get down to details
senior environment artist Jonas Madison
was on hand to answer our questions
about the vast world of The Witcher but
don't worry we'll keep this super light
in terms of story spoilers if you have
any more specific questions about the
story feel free to hit me up on Twitter
not Daniel Dwyer so the entire world of
The Witcher isn't one big map it's
actually broken up into two large maps
the smaller prologue map and a number of
closed-off levels inside the main
continent in the last video we
introduced you to the prologue area of
the game around the town of white
orchard this is where you spend the
first couple of hours of the game but
it's tiny in comparison to what comes
next
the main open world of the northern
realms comprises of a vast area
stretching from the city of novigrad in
the north down into a rich and beautiful
rural area which descends into no-man's
land an area containing a warfront
swamps and plenty of abandoned villages
so you have the big city in the north
the metropolitan and as you moved south
to coming to this war-torn the ravaged
area which all you also saw a little bit
of and that's one huge open world a
second separate open world a Skellig
islands is an archipelago to the west of
the main continent this is reachable
only by a fast travel boat ride which
constitutes one of the very few times
you'll be forced to hit a loading screen
these islands are varied more sparse and
wild and of gorgeous weather effects
from snow storms to sun-swept valleys
then there are enclosed areas which you
can only travel to via the games map
we've seen two of them firstly the Royal
Palace in vizima and secondly the home
of the witch's care [ __ ] which exists
to the far north of the main map there
could be more of these and we couldn't
travel to care more in during our time
but we did learn that you'll be fighting
alongside other witches there later in
the game and that's to say nothing of
the story beats with ciri the games
other playable character but we'll get
to those in the next video you're also
free to return to the prologue area of
the game and anytime to complete any
remaining side quests explore the world
or simply get in a fistfight with the
local cops
of course this is just what exists in
the immortal realm
CD Projekt are hiding some of the more
fantastical places up their sleeves I
don't really want to spoil this story
okay but there are certain places there
are places in the world that you will
you will come across this quite
non-natural and odd-looking definitely
so let's talk about the Maine open world
first of all it's bloody big I attempted
to run from the center of the map all
the way to novigrad and its northern
limit and even that took me about 20
minutes on horseback but granted I
probably didn't take the most direct
route mostly because the land here is
more dense than a lot of other open
worlds villages are numerous and packed
tightly together each with its own
message board full of side quests and
stories and as you wander into these new
villages there signposts become new fast
travel locations you ride with your
horse you stop and you see something's
over there you want to go there you want
to explore and see what you can find
them maybe you come across a village on
the way maybe there's a monster hunting
quest so it's all this kind of things
just happens and this is what we wanted
to have with the game where when you
explore the overworld apparently
everyone in the village has their own
routines and schedules from sunrise to
sunset unless of course it starts
raining we have lots of different types
of weather of course but important thing
to note this is not only cosmetic effect
it actually has an effect on community
so you know there were all rains I
better find shelter
you know it's nighttime people pack up
their things from the markets square and
go home but also monsters some monsters
are affected by the weather so when you
go monster hunting depending on the
monster you have to pay attention to
what time of day it is but the world of
The Witcher 3 isn't all just rolling
hills and swamps the vast city of
novigrad lies to the north with boats
bars and brothels for you to enjoy it's
a bustling vibrant city full of life and
from the sound of things we're gonna be
spending a lot of time there novigrad
isn't as large as say the cities and
Assassin's Creed but it's detail it's
quite impressive
streets packed with citizens bustling
bars and brothels you can wander into it
at a single loading screen walking into
novigrad is one of those times that the
witcher's technical prowess is on full
display hmm so one question you guys
keep asking us is how does this look on
console it's obviously when we went and
played the game we were playing the PC
version as you can see from the trailers
and the 4k screenshots looks pretty
great yeah but while we're at set a
project red we
she got a little sneak peek at the
console versions at Oh PS for an Xbox
one in this room where they were testing
performance for those versions you so
set it up for visual parodies
that's incredible yes we played a bit
six hours of the PC version yeah that's
great to see those are they look
fantastic
excellent on ps4 was it wonderful they
were sort of tweaking how it looked for
a frame rate optimisation while we were
there so a little bit of frame with
hitching obviously this is two months
before the game came out so we're both
cautiously optimistic that it'll look
good on those consoles in fact as we
went in beforehand we were thinking I
will probably get it on PC but by the
time we left that room we thought you
know what I think I might be alright to
play it on ps4 Xbox one in any case
however it looked in terms of the
framerate stuff this was definitely the
best open-world game I've seen running
on a current gen console but as
technically impressive and beautiful as
novigrad is to behold you must be sure
to tread carefully while wandering
through a less populated part of the
city a group of high-level bandits tried
to mug me evil lurks under grant to the
sewers of novigrad are vast and full of
monsters so we expect some quests in the
city will involve subterranean pest
control this shouldn't be a problem for
you though after all you play as Geralt
of Rivia famed monster hunter you be
hunting monsters throughout your time in
his shoes and according to lead
character artist pavel melanie check he
probably won't run out of them well of
course always we start from some
estimations right but the game grew so
much from the beginning from the initial
concept of the game the guy I don't know
the exact numbers of course but I feel
that the game is free or four times
bigger than I initially planned it to be
so also the the bigger region was the B
areas the maps you explore they you need
to create of course more monsters to
occupy you during the gameplay so I
remember like just two Asians is like
you know
the morning some end of production of
the game almost and I get an email hey I
know it's pretty late but we need some
additional twenty monsters so how many
of those I don't know many when you have
bigger smaller medium-sized monsters all
of them with good reason CD Projekt are
keeping tight-lipped on the types of
monsters you'll encounter but from what
we've seen from both playing the game
and their trailers there's a lot of
variety though we have muscles that are
also spreading fire we have most of that
are happening hypnotizing you we are
monsters that are disappearing and
running away you know or going
underground so every monster requires
different tactics actually so those
involve crossbow using the that the
bombs and the petals girls has using
special potions or even using science
science for example when you fight a
noon right you're not actually able to
kill it without using science there are
large bus style monsters you'll fight
one-on-one that there are pack monsters
like drowners or the horrible exploding
zombies known as rot fiends there are
water hags you can evade you with ease
while you're in the swamps and just when
you think you've seen it all and it
can't possibly get any more disgusting
or weird you stumble upon a demonic
miscarriage fetus hungry for revenge
chose a lovely spot damn it's will you
relent or plowing now I've done wrong
good the graves dug up and empty what's
that mean watch things on the prowl
look yeah
nightmares for days and then there's the
wildlife packs of wolves deer to hunt I
fought a bear within the first few
minutes of leaving the prologue area and
of course the greatest monster of them
all humans groups of bandits can be
found across the lands and killing them
can be just as satisfying for their
first jaunt into open world game design
CD Projekt have managed to make a world
with a great breadth of variety I spent
my first few hours here just wandering
around riding my trusty steed Roach into
bandit camps sailing a boat downriver
discovering ruins enjoying the sunset
unlocking new towns to fast travel from
and running from fights with monsters
that were clearly above my level you
know in many ways Wild Hunt doesn't
really feel like a witcher game it feels
closer to a fantasy version of Red Dead
Redemption you're kind of exploring the
wilderness and running into towns and
picking up quests but what type of
quests tomorrow on gamespot in part
three we detailed the gameplay of The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt its main quest
secondary quest side quests random
encounters and everything else you'll be
doing in this wonderful impressive
open-world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]